why do humans need sleep
let's let's go with a big first question
okay well the answer i'll start with
is the one that i always default to when
there's a why question
which is uh i wasn't consulted at the
design phase
so so so i wriggle my way out of giving
a
absolute answer right but
there's one mechanism that's very clear
that's super important which is that the
longer we are awake
the more adenosine accumulates
in our brain and adenosine binds to
adenosine receptors no surprise there
and it creates the feeling of sleepiness
independent of time of day or night
so there are two mechanisms one is we
get sleepy
as adenosine accumulates the longer
we've been awake the more adenosine is
accumulated in our system
but how sleepy we get
for a given amount of adenosine depends
on where we are in this so-called
circadian cycle
and the circadian cycle is just this
very very well conserved oscillation
it's a temperature oscillation where you
go from a low point
typically if you're awake during the day
and you're asleep at night you'll
your lowest temperature point will be
like 3 a.m 4 a.m and then your
temperature will start to creep up
as you wake up in the morning and then
it'll peak in the late afternoon
and then it'll start to drop again
toward the evening and then you get
sleep again that oscillation
in temperature takes 24 hours
temperature
yeah plus or minus an hour and i
don't even though i wasn't consulted at
the design phase i do not think it's a
coincidence
that it's aligned to the 24-hour spin of
the earth on its axis
the fact that we tend to be bathed in
sunlight
for a portion of that spin and in
darkness for the other portion that's
been so there are two mechanisms the
adenosine accumulation and the circadian
time point that we happen to be at and
those converge to
create a sense of sleepiness and
wakefulness the simple way
to reveal these two mechanisms to
uncouple them is stay up for 24 hours
and you will find that even though
you've been let's say you stay up
midnight 2 a.m
3 a.m provided you're on a regular
schedule
like that i follow not like the kind
that you follow uh
you get i will get very sleepy around 3
4 a.m
but then around 5 or 6 or 7 a.m which is
my normal wake-up time i'll start to
feel
more alert even though adenosine has
been accumulating
further so adenosine is higher for me
the longer i stay up and yet i feel more
alert than i did a few hours ago and
that's because these are two
interacting forces so adenosine makes
you sleepy and then just how sleepy or
how awake you feel also depends on where
you are in this temperature oscillation
that takes 24 hours
you